Can you recommend a supplement or diet program to ward off dementia? My mother died with it
and I want to prevent it. There is a really good test that came out a couple years ago. It's
through Syrex Labs. It's called Alzheimer's Leaks. That's a really good test. But even if you
ran that test and everything was normal on that test, there's things that we should all do
for a preventative standpoint for dementia. So if I don't have, let's say, any major symptoms of
dementia, and I don't really want to spend the money on that test, what are some things,
maybe this is a question the person asked me, what are some things that a person could do
to ward off dementia? Number one, you do things to decrease inflammation because inflammation
of the gut equals inflammation of the brain. So if you are eating foods that is causing
a inflammatory response of the gut, you're going to cause inflammation of the brain, especially with
gluten or dairy. You have gluteal morphine in case you have morphine receptors of the gut that
fire inflammatory receptors of the brain and you're going to cause inflammation of the brain.
Any inflammation of the brain is going to lead to issues. So especially when you have excess
inflammation, it's going to lead to issues. One can cause inflammation of the brain. Like I said,
the problem is with the gut. Secondly, post-concussive issues, even if you've had, you know, never
ever getting knocked out. If you've got the head, you pull it out as a kid, you play sports as a kid,
you play soccer than the worst. Heady, the ball, the soccer. You know, you've had falls, slipping,
pulling your head on different things. Even a dozen, two dozen years ago, can cause inflammatory
issues in the brain that are long-standing. I have a video. If you go to cuttersplinic.com, you
search neuroinflammation. I have a front half hour video on neuroinflammation and microglial
primate because the microglial cells are responsible for scavenging bad guys in the brain and are for
helping decrease inflammatory cytokites in the brain. So looking at that would be highly beneficial.
It's a half hour of your life, but it could save you from early dementia issues. So the thing you
want to do for dementia is decrease inflammation. Like I said, gut issues, cause inflammation of the
brain, post-concussive syndrome, even dozens of years ago, cause inflammation of the brain and
microglial primate. I'm going to say these little things that they inject in your arm that have
adjuvings, need to have adjuvings. They don't work without adjuvings. Adjuvings are other chemicals
that they have to add to that solution that they inject in your arm. Those adjuvings
cross the blood brain barrier and damage the blood brain barrier. Blood brain barriers is
basically another type of glial cell, your astrocytes that wrap around the blood vessels of the brain
and they can become damaged by chemicals and those chemicals can be damaged. It is said that
oh, the little bit of mercury or the little bit of aluminum that's in these fluid shots
are, is a nano aluminum. So it's hardly noticeable. It's hardly a problem. Well, that's actually even
way, way worse. Maybe a hundred times worse for you. If you sucked on a piece of aluminum, you're
getting elemental aluminum, that's bad. You should do that, right? But if you're kind of healthy,
got realistically, you're probably not going to absorb any of that and you're going to deposit
into the toilet. If you eject it in your arm and it's nano sized, it's going to, it's going to
immediately cross any blood brain barrier when it circulates through the brain and across the blood
brain barrier, anything that gets into the brain, whether it's a toxin or whether it's a biotoxin
infection, H by lower right, Lyme disease, etc. It's going to cause this huge inflammatory
response. The whole idea of you want to prevent disease, certainly dementia and any brain-based
diseases, Parkinson's issues with autoimmune neurological issues, you have to decrease inflammation.
So that's a number one. Simple and wise, what do you use to decrease inflammation generally in the
brain and in the rest of the body is the flavonoids. I do explain that a little bit on that video as well.
So go to cuttersclinic.com search for neuroinflammation and you'll see that. But flavonoids are
curcumin, resveratrol, green tea extract, corseted, stiggy dettles, etc. So there's lots of
different flavonoids that can be anti-inflammatory, call me down inflammation. But if you have a source
of inflammation that you're constantly exposing your body to, well, you could swim in
curcumin and it's going to do you less good. So you've got to decrease the source of inflammation.